[Music]  it's time for et social study your quick  look at what the stars are posting  online tell me a secret  about this dress it's completely  see-through Demi Lovato went sheer on  the Grammys red carpet and again on  Instagram check out the 24 year olds  insanely fit figure in this glitzy  bodysuit surprise  I love the element of surprise Amber  Rose surprised fans on social media  sharing this photo of her newest tattoo  man let me Bubbe Vanessa Lachey showed  off her nearly two month old son Phoenix  on Instagram while several other celebs  were busy hanging with their kids at New  York Fashion Week  Coco Austin her hubby ice-t and their  baby girl Chanel made the rookie USA  show a family affair Kevin Jonas sat  front row with his daughter Elena over  at the Carmen Marc Valvo Show Alec  Baldwin hung out backstage with his wife  hilarya and their three-year-old Carmen  [Music]  you